SPEAKER: I have the honor of
introducing our guest speaker
today, Dr. Rasmus Nielsen, who
is the Director of Research
at Oxford's Reuters Institute
for the Study of Journalism.
And he also serves
as Editor in Chief
for the "International
Journal of Press Politics."
His work focuses on the
changes in the news media,
on political communication,
and the role of technology
that it plays in both.
He's done extensive
research on journalism
and American politics as well
as various forms of activism.
He's received many awards
throughout his career
and has a PhD in communication
from Columbia University.
He will be sharing
some research that he's
done globally on the use of--
or the use of journalism
and social media
and how it's consumed
on digital media.
That'll be a 20-minute
presentation.
We'll then ask Erica
Anderson, our very own,
who heads up the Partnerships
Team in the News Lab, based out
of New York as
well, to do a Q&A.
I learned a lot about Erica
along the way as well.
Her current role is working
with partnerships in the news
industry and seeing how we can
really broadcast and advance
storytelling.
Building trust in this digital
age with the news industry.
Prior to Google, she was Katie
Couric's first social media
person, helping establish Katie
Couric as the first journalist
to really lead the
way in social media.
And prior to that,
she was at Twitter
helping establish the program
with journalists, fun fact,
helping build long codes
so that journalists
can tweet from remote
regions in war zones
using some satellite phones.
Such esteemed speakers
that we have today.
Please join me in giving a warm
welcome to Dr. Rasmus Nielsen
and Erica Anderson.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Welcome.
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Thank you.
Thanks very much for
the warm introduction
and for the opportunity
to speak here today.
I will talk on the basis of a
large collaborative research
project that we do at
the Reuters Institute
at the University
of Oxford that's
led up by my colleague,
Nic Newman, Richard
Fletcher, Antonis
Kalogeropoulos, David
Levy, and myself.
So I will sort of
speak on behalf of what
really is a team effort.
And I'm just the one who
has the honor, if you will,
to stand here in front of you
to talk about these issues.
What I want to do is to give
a big picture overview, what's
happening to how people use
media, how they use news, how
they get it across a range
of different countries
across the world.
I'll touch on some key
themes around these issues
and try to take away some
of the big picture points
that I think are
relevant for thinking
about the role of
journalism in our societies
but also the role of large
technology companies,
like Google.
So first, a quick overview
of what the study is about.
We do a large survey every year.
This year, we have covered
36 different markets
across the world, a total
of 70,000 respondents,
more than 2,000 in every
country that we cover,
to really give a
picture globally
of how people are using media
and news across the world.
This is made possible
by a network of partners
and sponsors, including a
range of different media
organizations, like the BBC;
media regulators, like Ofcom
in the UK; private
sector media companies,
including publishers,
newspapers,
and the like; universities
and technology companies,
like Google, who is
amongst the sponsors
behind this
collaborative effort.
I want to touch on a set of
key findings from this survey
today before we open up for
conversation with Erica.
And I'll run through
each of them in turn.
The first point I
want to talk about
is the move towards
an environment of what
we might think of as distributed
discovery, where people
increasingly get their news not
by going direct to the websites
and apps of news organizations,
but by coming sideways
via search, via social,
and increasingly,
via messaging apps
or other forms
of distributed discovery, where
contrary to fears of filter
bubbles, at least
in our research,
we find that people, in
fact, are increasingly more
exposed to more
different sources of news
than they were in the past.
But also, an environment
in which people
don't always recognize the
brands or the sources of news
that they have, in fact, used.
The second point I want to
cover is the question of trust.
And I will argue that our
research shows that confidence
both in social media
and in news media is low
in many environments
and particularly
in those that are politically
polarized, like the US.
I will talk about the evolving
role of platform companies,
like Google, in terms of the
way in which we, as users, use
the technologies that companies
like Google, Facebook,
and Apple, and others
are offering is changing
the way in which we get news.
And finally, I will talk about
mobile and the centrality
of the smartphone as the
defining device of news today
and, if you will,
the implications
of these developments for
the business of journalism.
So this is the terrain.
The first topic is the question
of distributed environments.
Now, it's clear that in the
early days of the internet,
we still lived in a world in
which people primarily got news
by going direct to a source of
news, a brand that they knew.
They would type in
thenewyorktimes.com,
or still maybe use
a print newspaper
or go to a broadcaster
for their news.
But increasingly, the
world in which we live
is one in which people have
embraced what we might think
of as distributed discovery,
where we come across news
via platform services that are
sometimes used because we want
news but sometimes
incidentally expose us to news
while we are using the platform
or service for other purposes.
In our survey, by
now most people
would say that they get news
in a range of different ways.
Sometimes, going direct.
Sometimes, use of
social or search.
But when we do a
follow-up question
of asking people, what is
your main way of getting news
online, we clearly see this
shift towards an environment
that is more distributed.
So by now, in the
countries we cover,
the 36 different
markets, about a third
say that going direct
to a news provider
is their main way of
getting news online.
But 2/3 mentioned various
forms of distributed access.
Search most importantly,
social close behind, and then
other forms of sideways access.
Amongst younger
users, those under 35,
it's 3/4 who named these
distributed forms of access
as their main way
of getting news.
Many people have worried that
this development would lead us
towards an environment
characterized by filter bubbles
or echo chambers where
algorithmic selection would
lead us just to feed us more
of what we already want.
In fact, when we look
at our survey data,
what we find consistently across
the markets that we look at is
that those people who use
social media or search, or both,
amongst the ways in which they
find news are consistently
exposed to more different
sources of news in the course
of a week than those who don't.
Now, it's important
to say here that,
of course, for those people
who use a lot of news,
this effect may
be quite marginal.
So if you use maybe five
or seven different sources
of news in a week,
you're probably
not going to see more
different sources
of news via search and social.
But what's important to remember
is that most people do not
use a lot of sources of news.
They might use two or three
that they go to directly.
And search and social in general
will add additional sources
that they would not have
come across otherwise.
So we really don't find
these filter bubbles
or echo chambers.
In fact, we find the opposite--
incidental exposure to news
that people would not
have sought out otherwise,
in particular for young people
and for those least interested
in news.
The flip side of this,
which we could broadly
say is probably a good
thing, if you will,
is that there is a clear
issue of brand recognition
in this environment.
That people don't always
remember or even recognize
the news providers
that they come across
via search or social.
So this year in the UK, we
did sort of a closed study,
particularly of this
question of attribution,
where we tracked
people passively,
looking at what they
actually accessed,
a set of panelists who
had volunteered to let
their behavior be tracked.
We identified the ways in
which people came across news--
by going direct, by accessing
first a social media
domain and then a news site, or
using search and then accessing
a news site.
And then we would survey
those people within 48 hours,
knowing that they had
accessed a certain news story,
and asked them, do you
remember where you got it?
What news brand did you
get this story from?
Unsurprisingly, most of
the people who had directly
accessed the news
organization would correctly
recall what news organization
this was-- the BBC, The Mail
Online, The Guardian.
Whereas less than
half of those who
had come across this
story via search or social
could correctly remember and
recall what the brand behind it
was actually like.
So here is a real issue that
is in part, if you will,
an issue for publishers
around their business
and the standing of
their journalism.
But also it's a public
issue in the sense
that we know from
a lot of research
that brands are key to the
ways in which people think
about the credibility
of information,
and the trustworthiness
and the degree to which they
will let that information
influence or inform
their views, if you will.
So there is an issue here
of whether in distributed
environments, we are
helped enough as users
to actually navigate the
information that we discover
via the search and
social services.
The next topic I
want to touch on
is this question of
confidence and trust,
which sort of follows
on, if you will,
in some ways from this question
of distributed discovery
and whether we recognize
brands in that environment.
The first thing I
want to say here
is that we asked
people in this survey
as sort of a simple top-line
question of whether they felt
that different ways
of getting news
helped them distinguish
between fact and fiction.
So it was sort of
a way of trying
to get at this
issue of fake news
that didn't rely on
simply asking people.
So, Rasmus, do you feel like
you've been fooled recently?
And then me sort
of volunteering,
yes, I've been
fooled all the time.
No.
Instead we asked
people whether they
felt empowered by
different forms of media
to distinguish between
fact and fiction.
Now, the first figure there
is quite striking, we feel.
It's that only a quarter
of our respondents, 24%,
feel that social media
helps them distinguish
between fact and fiction.
Now, obviously, this
has never been a promise
that social media made.
It is not something that social
media platforms promised people
to help them do this, but
it is still quite striking
that when we know that
so many people rely
on social media as one among
several sources of ways
of finding news that so few
people seem to think that this
is actually a good way for them
to distinguish between fact
and fiction.
The optimistic spin
on this, if you will,
is that people
are actually quite
skeptical of this information.
And this image that some people
have of people sort of naively
believing every
piece of information
that they come across
on Twitter, on Facebook,
is not one we can
recognize at all.
To the contrary,
our data suggests
that people are highly
skeptical and quite critical
consumers of information
that they find
in distributed environments.
When we turn to news media,
the figure is much higher.
40% say that they feel news
media helped them distinguish
between fact and fiction.
Whether the figure is
as high as journalists
would like it to be is then
a separate question because
of course, here
journalists actually
do believe that
this is what they
are trying to do in many cases.
So the figure here,
if you will, is
one I think that
indicates that there
is a much broader issue of trust
and confidence in news media
that I think has been
illustrated quite vividly
recently in the United
States around elections
and, if you will, the attitudes
of certain politicians
and parts of the public
towards journalists and media
organizations.
But it's important to
see here that this,
while a global phenomenon,
is not equally pronounced
or the same level, if
you will, of distrust
or even crisis of confidence in
every country around the world.
So looking across the 36
markets we cover in the report,
we find very
pronounced differences
in degree to which people say
that they can trust the media.
Some countries, often
in Northern Europe,
have half or close to
half the population saying
they have a lot or quite a
lot of confidence in the news
media.
Whereas in countries like
the US, it's less than 40%.
And many very
polarized countries
in Southern Europe,
Central, Eastern Europe,
and Latin America have
even lower levels of trust
like that, like
Greece, for example,
and Korea, where only about
a quarter of the population
feel that they can
trust the media.
Now, a subset of this
is a follow-up question
about whether people trust not
the media, but my media, if you
will, the media that they use.
And in polarized
societies like the US,
we see very big differences,
where people are much more
likely to say that they
trust the media that they
use than they are
to say that they
trust the media in general--
implicitly, the media
that other people use.
Whereas in many of the countries
with high levels of trust,
people trust both their
own media and the media
that other people use, which
is a slightly different
environment.
In our view, this
is in large part
due to political polarization.
So something that
may be accentuated
by media and by technology,
but it's fundamentally
a political question.
We tried to map this by showing
the degree to which audiences
are distributed along
partisan political lines
in the online environment.
And you can see, for example,
in a country like the United
States, that you have
a majority of brands
that have an audience
that leans to the left.
I should underline
here, this graph
is about the audience's
political leaning,
not about the
content or editorial
line of these organizations.
But a large number of brands
who have left-leaning audiences,
and then a few who have
right-leaning audiences,
and very little in the
middle, apart from Yahoo News.
A country like the
UK, where you have
a large provider in the middle,
the public service media
organization, the BBC;
a number of newspapers
that are sort of clearly
center left or center
right, whether it's The
Mail Online, The Telegraph,
or The Guardian, and
The Daily Mirror;
and then very small,
very purely partisan
outlets on the far
left and the far right.
So this is quite a
different picture,
if you will, of
what an online media
environment, a high-choice
media environment,
might look like in a country
that is less politically
polarized than the US and
where people generally
have higher levels of
confidence in the media,
though declining,
perhaps, after Brexit.
Now, the next topic I wanted
to quickly walk through
is this question of the evolving
role of platform companies,
and how we find and
access news, and the way
in which these things
are changing over time.
The first point here
is really, of course,
to highlight the
centrality of social media,
by now the only
sort of other way,
apart from search, that really
is central to distributed
discovery.
And we've seen an
incredibly rapid rise
in the role of social
media for getting news.
By now, in 2017, more than
half of our US respondents
say that they get
news on social media.
It's basically a doubling
in just four years.
The development in the
UK is very similar.
But what's important
to recognize here also
is that, actually, this year
we've seen, if you will,
a slowing down or even a
flat-lining of this seemingly
inexorable growth of the
roles of social media.
So in many countries,
the number of people
who say they get news from
social media has stayed flat
or even declined
slightly year-on-year.
And again, there
are very pronounced
country-to-country differences
between a country like Germany
versus a country
like Spain, where
in Spain, twice
as many people say
they get news on social media.
So social media, perhaps a
saturation point, the same way
that search may have
reached saturation
as one of the ways in
which people get news.
Where do we see
the evolution then?
Well, from our point of
view, the next frontier
is probably messaging
applications.
This is where we've seen
real growth year-on-year,
in particular WhatsApp,
Facebook Messenger, but also
in some countries,
individual other providers.
So we have Snapchat
that are important
for some demographics-- younger
users in many countries,
particularly the US and some
other English-speaking markets.
But also in some
countries, there
are individual
messaging applications
that are very important--
Kakao in Korea, for
example, and Line in Japan.
So we see a lot
of difference here
in the role of messaging apps.
These more private
environments that
are not filtered by algorithms
making display decisions
but are filtered
by users deciding
who they want to share
with that in some markets
are really, really important.
Already now we have,
in some markets,
generally markets with low
levels of trust in mainstream
media and with highly-polarized
environments where you may not
want to talk about politics
publicly on social media,
but may want to talk about
politics privately with people
you trust, we see countries
that in some cases,
like Malaysia and Brazil,
it's half or close to half
of the population say that they
get news via messaging apps.
This really is a new
frontier that publishers
are interested in looking at.
But also, of course,
a whole new set
of questions around the
spread of information
and all the wonderful
ways in which this
can empower people to share
things and get informed.
But also, of course, the
fears around misinformation
and an environment in which
it's much harder to really track
what kind of information
do people actually
get in these environments
that are not public and not
transparent from the outside.
The next frontier
perhaps might be voice.
Many companies are
investing in this,
Amazon and Google included.
And many publishers are
interested in this question
of whether voice
provides a new interface,
whether via smart speakers
or also via smartphones,
and increasingly are
offering not only responses
to voice queries, but
also a voice response
to the query, if you will,
in terms of giving people
the news via these devices.
And we expect to see some growth
in this area moving forward.
This is clearly a priority
for technology companies.
And publishers may be able
to leverage this growth.
The fourth issue I wanted
to talk about is mobile.
Really the mobile phone,
our data suggests,
increasingly is the defining
device of digital news.
And again, a bit like the
growth of social media,
it's a development
that I think by now
is so naturalized
for many people who
might be in this room or
listening to this talk,
we take it for granted because
for us, the mobile phone is
already the remote control
to much of our life
and our digital life.
But I think it's
worth remembering just
how incredibly rapid
this growth has been,
how quickly this has transformed
the environment for publishers
and for a lot of people
who didn't necessarily
grow up with a smartphone
sort of glued to their ear.
We see a rapid shift where
this year, for the first time,
we reached a tipping point
where the same number of people
in the US identify their
smartphone as their main device
for getting digital news as
identify a personal computer.
And again, just look at
the pace of development
here in just three years as a
move from a situation in which
less than a fifth would
say the smartphone
was their main
device for getting
digital news to a situation in
which 40% of the respondents,
and if you include tablets, well
over half of the respondents
say that their mobile device is
their main way of getting news.
So this is a very
rapid development.
And of course, it
creates a new environment
where we start accessing news
in all these sort of found time,
these little pockets of
time throughout our day
that previously weren't
necessarily connected
with media use.
We all recognize that
experience of waiting
for a friend at a cafe.
We flip out the phone.
Sitting in the back of a
cab, we flip out the phone.
Waiting for the subway,
flip out the phone.
And there are all these, if
you will, new moments early
in the morning, even
before we get out of bed,
tending to other private needs.
Or for that matter, using
public transportation
where there are these new
moments where people can access
media content in ways that were
almost unimaginable, if you
will, just a few years ago,
where we were still tied
to devices that were
largely desk-bound or using
print and broadcast in
quite traditional ways.
And this is a new situation
full of opportunities
for platform companies
and for publishers alike.
And of course, also one
where increasingly we are all
competing for attention,
precious, precious attention
of getting onto the lock
screen of these supercomputers
we increasingly all
carry in our pockets.
So head-to-head
competition for attention.
Publishers are
pushing back here.
Publishers who may
have felt that they
were in a zero-sum game between
platforms and publishers
are in some markets by
now really leveraging
this mobile opportunity
to get their alerts
onto the lock screen
of smartphones.
We see a resurgent
interest in mobile apps.
We see mobile alerts.
We see email newsletters.
We see the different ways in
which publishers are really
fighting back to capture a share
of people's attention in part
by leveraging this
mobile opportunity.
But again, of
course, this is also
linked to the rise of
platforms in the sense
that we know from our research
that people who use mobile
are also more likely
to use social media
and search to get news, even
controlling for other factors.
So the rise of mobile
and the rise of platforms
here is interlinked.
And though publishers
are fighting back,
it is clear that platform
companies have often
been the best at
serving the mobile user
and better than
publishers in many cases
and for many problems.
This leads me to the question
of the business of journalism.
And I think in
some ways, this is
where things get a little
bit trickier in the sense
that in many ways, the
world that we are describing
with our research
and our data is
a wonderful world in many
ways, much better than the one
I grew up in, where multi
sort of media diversity
meant a couple of
different print newspapers
and a couple of different
broadcast channels.
This is a much better world
from my point of view as a user.
I have access to more different
sources of information
than ever before.
They are generally free at
the point of consumption.
I can find them
in many more ways.
They are more
conveniently available
through my mobile phone than
they ever were in the past.
This is great.
And it's even a world in
which, contrary to fear
of filter bubbles and
the like, we actually
find that many people are
exposed to much more news
than they would seek out
of their own volition.
But there is a catch,
which is the question
of the funding of this news,
the professional production
of journalism.
And it is worth
keeping in mind here
that when we look at who
invests in professional news
production, which,
warts and all--
nothing is perfect-- we
know from a lot of research
helps people be more
informed about public life,
help people be more engaged
with local communities,
help people take part in
the political process.
So again, news is not perfect.
News is very far from
perfect, but we know from lots
of research it has positive
civic and political
consequences when people
actually engage with
professionally-produced
journalism and that
the existence of
such journalism--
again, with all its
imperfections-- demonstrably
help hold power to account,
reduce corruption and the
like in countries
around the world
and communities
around the world.
Who invests in this journalism?
Well, in this
country, even today--
that skipped one slide--
about 60% of investment
in professionally-produced
journalism, if we go by the
Bureau of Labor Statistics,
employment of reporters
and correspondents
comes from print publishers.
Newspaper organizations who
still generally make 80% or 90%
of their revenues from
their offline operations
that are in steep decline and
who are investing ambitiously
in their digital
operations and are reaching
significant audiences there
but are facing difficulties
in getting a return
on that investment
and generating a profit from
their digital investments.
So news is still primarily
funded by newspaper publishers
with their digital
operations, but much
of the revenue coming from
legacy operations and print.
And online media information
is a much smaller part of this.
Though, of course, it is a
much larger share of people's
attention and of the advertising
market, increasingly.
The funding?
Well, historically the
funding in the United States,
in particular, came
from advertising.
Newspaper publishers
historically
made something like 80% or
even 90% of their revenues
from advertising.
That advertising
now increasingly
goes to digital media.
This is a well-known story.
American newspapers used to
make something like $60 billion
a year in print advertising.
Now it's more like 20.
And digital, of course, has
grown very, very rapidly.
When it comes to
digital advertising,
they are competing head-to-head
with very, very successful
companies, like Google.
So when we look at the share of
digital advertising globally,
these are estimates of the share
captured by two large platform
companies.
Blue at the bottom is Google.
The pinkish color is Facebook.
And then the orange
part at the top--
about half of the pie--
is what everybody
else in the world
competes for in terms
of digital advertising.
So advertising alone has been a
very tough business proposition
for the professional
production of journalism,
which can be quite
expensive and where
the average revenues per user
for the digital operation
has been quite low.
And advertising has
been tough to get
to generate the kind of
revenues that publishers
have been hoping
for and that they
have generated in the past.
So many have turned to pay.
We find in our survey that 13%
of our respondents across 36
markets say that they pay in
some form for news online.
Highest in the Nordic
countries in Europe,
lower in a country like the
UK, where I live currently.
And in this country,
in the US, we
have seen evidence of what we
think of as sort of a "Trump
bump," if you will, where
a number of publishers
have seen a real increase in the
number of people who have been
willing to pay for
their journalism,
perhaps in part
because of this more
polarized political environment,
where there's been attacks
on the value of journalism
but also a certain rallying,
if you will, around
the importance
of journalistic organizations
as part of the functioning
democracy.
And we've seen individual
titles, whether The Wall Street
Journal, "The New Yorker,"
or The New York Times
reportedly benefiting from this.
And we see, again, in the
survey a clear upwards tick
in the number of people
who pays for news.
Now, while it is a challenging
environment for publishers,
I think there is no
question that there is also
opportunities ahead.
And I think one of the
opportunities ahead
really is this, if you
will, increasing evidence
that if you do really good
journalism that really connects
with the problems that
people actually have,
the concerns that they
actually care about,
and if you are able to serve
it to them in a way that
is convenient, whether that
is via platform companies
or through your own
apps and websites,
or some combination
thereof, you can not only
monetize that attention
through advertising
and other auxiliary revenues,
but also increasingly convince
people this is actually
worth paying for.
This has value that I will
pay honest dollars for.
And importantly, it
is not only those
who already pay for print.
It is not only older people
who are willing to pay.
So when you break
down the pay behavior
by age, contrary to this
idea that some older
sort of commentators on the
digital media environment may--
the comments they
may make sometimes,
it's not a question of
sort of millennials,
quote unquote, "to be the
blame for all this stuff."
In fact, we find
that younger people
are more likely to say that
they're paying for news online.
Probably, in large
part, at least
we would argue,
because they don't
have a reference price of zero.
Unlike old people
like myself, who
have grown up in a world in
which everything online was
free--
and I'm sort of mildly
offended whenever
anyone wants to charge
me for something online.
I have to get used
to that idea that I
have to pay for
things online, just
as I have to pay
for things elsewhere
if I want something premium.
Younger people who
are younger than me
have grown up in an
environment where they've
been used to paying
for things online,
in particular on their phone,
from the get-go, whether these
are music services, like
Spotify, premium video
and entertainment, like
Netflix, or for that matter,
mobile applications
and games online.
And in that context, it is
no longer sort of shocking
or scandalous to suggest that
if you want a premium news
product, you may actually
have to pay for it.
And in fact, we
have, again, evidence
here that young people are no
less likely than older people
to pay for news.
And I think this
is, if you will,
an opportunity, a
business opportunity
to say to publishers that
not only is it the case today
that the best journalism is
better than it's ever been--
and also, from a user point
of view, easier to access,
easier to find,
more convenient--
it's also something that at
least a part of the population,
primarily more affluent and
privileged news lovers--
so there are issues of
social inequality here--
but that at least
some people find
it's actually worth paying for.
OK.
Key questions, and I'll
leave these on the slides
before we kick off the
discussion with Erica.
But from my point
of view, I suppose,
some of the key questions that
we are left with this research
is, first, the
question of whether we
can help more effectively
as researchers, as platform
companies, as publishers,
can help people
more effectively navigate this
distributed environment that
is so rich but also so
confusing in some cases and full
of pitfalls.
There's a question of whether
publishers and platforms can
help restore trust and
credibility in news
and information, I think is
another issue where there might
be space for shared action.
It is a question of whether
publishing platforms who
have co-existed, sometimes
fractiously, for quite
some time now have
learned enough
from that history
of collaboration
and occasional confrontations
to find a more mutually
satisfactory settlement for
coexistence in the future as we
move towards these new
forms of platform services,
whether messaging apps,
or voice-operated systems,
or for that matter,
virtual reality.
Whether we've learned
enough from the past
to find a better
settlement for the future
that works for publishers, for
platforms, and for the public,
too.
There is a question
about publishers, too.
About whether they
are sufficiently
ambitiously embracing
the opportunities
of this environment.
Or whether they are
sometimes, if you will,
captured by the
glory of their past
rather than the promise
of their future.
And finally, of course,
this question of money.
Who's going to pay?
And I hope we can get to grips
with those questions today.
So I look forward to the
discussion with Erica.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ERICA ANDERSON: Thank you.
Testing.
All right.
Thank you so much.
That was fascinating.
And I'm sure everyone
in the audience agrees.
Let's just take a step back.
So this is the sixth year
that Reuters Institute
has done this study.
This is the biggest one
by far, 36 countries.
I think you interviewed
70,000 people,
both quantitative and
qualitative research.
Like zoom out for us.
What was perhaps most
interesting or out of character
for this report that you saw
compared to the five before?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: I think
in some ways, this year,
with the expansion of the number
of countries we were covering,
I think the most important
findings are not always
surprising, if you will.
And I've tried to cover
some of them today.
But I think some of the ones
that were revelatory for us
and really
interesting are really
about the international
comparisons.
I believe very firmly that
just the same way as news
organizations and tech
companies elsewhere
can learn from what happens in a
country like the United States,
so, too, people here
can learn from what's
going on elsewhere in the world.
And I would highlight
two examples.
One is that journalists in
this country and commentators
in this country might feel that
an environment characterized
by political polarization, low
trust in political institutions
and the media, and
media organizations
with limited newsrooms and
often shrinking newsrooms
is sort of a shocking and
new situation in the US.
I have colleagues from Italy
and from Greece who would say,
welcome to the club.
This is nothing new.
And I think there is a real
idea there, if you will,
that we can sort of
use data like this
to start a
conversation about how
publishers and platforms,
for that matter,
in a country like this can learn
from the experience of people
elsewhere who have long
tried to have a functioning
public debate in
an environment that
was much more challenging than
the US was till not so long
ago.
The other I think
surprising finding
I would highlight in terms of
sort of the new things that
were new for us in this
year's report is I think the--
and again, as an
example, if you will,
of the value of
looking at developments
elsewhere to sort of supplement
one's understanding of one's
own national and
local context is
that it's been really
interesting to look
more closely at Asia-Pacific.
Where I think it's easy to
overlook for people in North
America and Western Europe that
many markets in Asia-Pacific--
Taiwan, Hong Kong,
to some extent
Japan and South Korea, and
Singapore, for that matter--
are technologically
ahead in many ways.
Higher levels of internet
use, higher levels
of smartphone use,
younger populations
who have taken to
digital media more
quickly than more aging
populations, in particular,
in Europe.
And I think it's
interesting to note
that in these
environments, while there
is no question that platform
companies are absolutely
central to how people
find and access news,
it is also clear that not
all publishers but the most
successful and
aggressive publishers
have been able to carve
out a role for themselves
in that environment.
Whether this is a tabloid title
like Apple Daily in Hong Kong
or The Straits
Times in Singapore,
that there are news
organizations there
that are really,
if you will, have
been-- have found a space in a
truly digital first and mobile
first and platform-shaped
environment that I think
many North American and Western
European publishers are only
beginning to
imagine, if you will.
ERICA ANDERSON: So you're
optimistic in looking at APAC
and seeing the collaboration?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Yeah.
I mean, I'm very
optimistic in many ways.
I think there are very,
very real challenges
around the question of the
business of journalism.
And I think that challenge
is one we cannot ignore.
The precondition of professional
and necessary but not
sufficient precondition for
professional autonomous news
production is profitability.
And if this cannot be achieved,
then there is a serious market
failure that has profound
democratic and public
implications.
But as serious as
that challenge is,
there is no question that in
many other ways, the media
environment we have today is
much better for our abilities
as citizens, provided
we have the inclination,
to find and access information
than it ever was in the past.
ERICA ANDERSON: Let's
take a step back
and talk about trust,
which you brought up
in showing the chart of trust
across the 36 countries,
and the point you made about
polarization in society leading
to less trust in news.
Just to quote the report, "less
than half the population, 43%,
trust the media across
all 36 countries surveyed.
And almost a third
actively avoid the news."
That number rises
to 38% in the US.
So for me, the headline there
is less trust equals less news.
If you don't trust the
news, you don't consume it.
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Yeah.
I mean, I think
there is a real--
two problems that are
compounding each other
around trust and confidence.
One is that this undermines
the ability of journalism
to play its role
in our democracy.
It also undermines the ability
of the business of news
to sustain journalism itself.
And this crisis of confidence,
I think in part, in large part,
is about politics.
Journalism primarily
covers public institutions.
And if those public
institutions themselves are
deeply riven with conflict
and are populated in part
by elected officials who not
only question the integrity
and motives of each
other, but also actively
campaign against
the news itself,
this has consequences
for people's perception
of journalism as well as
those public institutions.
I think there is also a question
in many cases of a disconnect
between the content produced
by even the best news
organizations and the
concerns of many individuals.
Whether these are around
issues of inequality
and marginalization, where
there are many people who
understandably do
not feel represented
by journalism in terms
of diversity, of gender,
of sexuality, of
race, and ethnicity,
whether it's around class--
increasingly,
journalism is basically
done by people like
me for people like me.
And there is a question about
whether a lot of very good--
otherwise very good journalism--
actually confronts the people--
the problems that people
feel that they have.
And there is, if
you will, sometimes
an issue of a risk
that people will
judge the totality of the
journalistic profession,
the output of the entire media
institution, by, if you will,
the excesses of the worst.
So this perception that because
much journalism, or at least
some journalism, is about
sensationalist coverage
of crime, terrorism,
celebrity gossip,
and the like, then surely all
journalism must be like this.
And then I don't want to pay
attention to it because it's
depressing and irrelevant.
ERICA ANDERSON: It certainly
feels like a crisis and one
that we've seen for
the last 10 years
with the changes
in, as you said,
decentralized distribution.
We're no longer
getting the newspaper
and reading it in the
morning with a cup of coffee.
Maybe some people are,
but habits are changing.
Revenue is changing.
Certainly, a lot
of disruption has
occurred on behalf of
technology and platforms.
But there are signs of life.
I mean, it's interesting.
You showed that
example about the,
quote unquote, "Trump bump."
That subscriptions
increased at least
for a few national
organizations.
I mean, talk to me.
What did you learn
about subscriptions
and the ways in which--
that really compelling
statistic that young people
are willing to pay for news?
You said earlier there's
this reference point.
They're willing to
pay for Spotify.
pay for Netflix.
They're willing to pay for news.
Talk about that if you can.
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Sure.
I mean, I want to stress that
the situation here is complex,
and there are real problems.
And I don't want to sugarcoat
any of those problems.
And those problems
are very often
around business as
well as politics.
But I also really want to
underline that it really
is the best of times
and the worst of times
at the same time.
I'm not a pessimist.
And I think in many ways,
again, the information available
and the ways in which we
can find this information
are vastly superior to the
ones that I grew up with.
I don't know anyone under
40 who would willingly
trade the media environment
we live in today for the one
that I grew up with.
And I share that view myself.
So it is a situation that's
characterized by many problems,
but not only problems--
also huge opportunities.
In terms of
willingness to pay, I
think there is a real
sort of question of how
to manage transition here.
A lot of news
organizations have,
for understandable reasons,
but perhaps in retrospect,
reasons that were a little bit
short-sighted-- this is not
a criticism of any
individual involved,
but simply an
observation-- have tended
to navigate by quite short-term
metrics of maximizing
page views that in turn were
used to sell advertising.
If you have done
that for 10 or 20
years and people have formed
their view of journalism
on the basis of encountering
your brand primarily
through the lens of things
that can uncharitably be called
"clickbait," then turning around
and saying, oh, by the way,
you should pay me
$20 a month for this,
is a tough transition to make.
And I think there is
quite a profound question
that a lot of news organizations
are really only beginning
to seriously ask
themselves, which is, what
is the problem that we solve?
OK?
Not the problem
we used to solve.
Not the problem that our
civics teacher in high school
will tell us that
we are solving,
but the problem that
we actually solve
for actual people
in our community.
What is that problem?
And can we actually solve that
in a way that is effectively
addressing the people of--
the issues faced by
real people out there,
and also done so in a way
that's convenient enough
to get their attention
and to get them to engage,
and is done in a way that
is cost-efficient enough
that one can do it on the basis
of revenues that will almost
inevitably be smaller than
the one news organizations had
in the 1990s?
ERICA ANDERSON: So I want
anyone in the audience
who have questions to
start thinking of those.
And please, line up if
you have a question.
Let's talk about social
media and messaging.
Because one of the
findings from the report
is actually consumption
of news on social media
is flattening out
in some places,
but there's a huge increase, I
think last year a 15% increase,
in people consuming
news on WhatsApp.
On Facebook Messenger,
I think there
were 30,000 bots, since that
started, delivering news.
So we're beginning to see
this transition, actually,
into closed networks, into
messaging apps for news.
Can you talk a little
bit about that--
what you see as the
trend, having spent time
in Hong Kong,
Singapore, in Asia?
What can the US or
European countries
learn from how news is
being delivered and consumed
through messaging apps?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: I
mean, I think those are all
early indications of how--
and again, this is
more than anything
a challenge for the
journalistic profession itself
and for those--
the wider ecosystem
of people who care about
it, whether ordinary users,
or platform companies, or
researchers like myself,
is the question
of, how do we think
about the act of
journalism itself
if we are leaving behind the
shackles of how journalism
was done in the past?
A lot of journalism is
still primarily produced
in the form of an
article that is
instantly recognizable as an
artifact of print technology.
It has the length.
It has the look.
It is largely dictated by how
things were done in the past.
It has evolved, but not much.
Or the short news clip that was
part of a broadcast bulletin,
two and a half minute video.
There's nothing wrong
with these formats.
I consume them everyday
myself-- sometimes gladly,
sometimes, with
mild disgruntlement.
But I think there is
a real question of,
what do we think about?
What is the act of
journalism or the profession
and the practice of journalism?
What does it look like
beyond the article?
What comes after the
article or the news clip?
What is the way in which
journalists can find a position
in that ecosystem, whether
it is the mobile experience
or this distributed
environment where
I think we have to accept
that for most people,
journalism will be a smaller
part of a larger media
experience than it
was in the past?
And I think in some ways, this
may be tough for the journalism
profession to confront.
But if it is a fact, then it's
incumbent on the profession
to face this fact
and then think about,
how can you solve
problems if you
have less of people's
attention or you
have to work harder to get it?
And I think that apps
are interesting here.
I think bots are
interesting here.
I think rethinking the format,
whether slideshows or videos.
And this whole idea
that increasingly, I
think some of the most
innovative thinkers
in the profession,
in the industry,
are thinking about
journalism as a service
rather than as a product.
Rather than just churning out,
frankly, 200 articles a day
or video enough for a
30-minute broadcast bulletin
that's then cut up and
loaded onto social media,
what does it look like if you're
no longer simply pushing out
a product, but trying
to think from the needs
of different
communities and serving
those needs in different ways?
ERICA ANDERSON: Yeah.
I'm curious, what platforms--
you talk a bit about platforms.
Obviously, we're here at Google.
We have a lot of people
inside the company working
to support journalists
and news organizations.
What have platforms done well?
What have they not
done enough of?
I mean, this is a transition.
It requires collaboration
and working together.
But from your perspective and
from what the report found,
what are your
perspectives on this?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: I
think the first thing to say
is that different platform
companies are different.
And different publishers
have different needs.
So there is no
one sort of recipe
for what this relationship
should look like.
And there is also, I think,
sometimes the slight risk
that when platforms
and publishers
start working together,
that the interests
of each individual
company can sometimes
overshadow the interests of the
user, the public, if you will.
And I think this is
a sort of a risk we
need to be conscious of.
I think there are real
issues now that are already
beginning to be addressed--
Google is involved in this.
Facebook is involved in this--
that are around trust
and verification.
So how to flak fake or
misleading content online,
how to try to help more
clearly communicate the brands
whose reputation are
behind the content
that people might come across.
Google has worked on this in the
AMP carousel in search results.
Facebook has just
announced the integration
of brands in the articles
that show up in the news feed
to sort of more clearly
communicate where
the information originates.
There's a whole set of
issues around helping
people navigate
this environment,
enabling effective use of it.
More fundamentally, I suppose
that the issue specifically
between platforms
and publishers have
been around editorial control.
So who makes the decisions
about what is displayed where?
And how can publishers
influence those
so that they feel that
their content is not
only discoverable, but also
discoverable in a context
that they feel content with?
And this has been a
very long discussion
between Google and publishers
as well as between Facebook
and publishers.
Many people in the
room will be aware,
going back to Google News
and Google Search more than--
many years ago.
It's around data.
So there is a question
of data that is
in part about commercial use.
Can data be shared in a
way that doesn't compromise
the privacy of users and that
enables not only platforms,
but also publishers to make
more informed decisions
about their content as
well as the advertising
and other forms of commercial
considerations that they have?
And then the final
one is revenue.
It's the question of, what is
a revenue split that reflects
the value being created?
And again, there's been a lot
of discussions around this
where some companies,
like Google,
have been invested in revenue
sharing around advertising.
But there are
publishers who have
considerations around this.
There are discussions
around Facebook
around this sort of
question of monetization
of revenue sharing.
And there is the question
of whether platforms--
in particular,
platforms in the West--
have been so
committed to an idea
or free at the
point of consumption
that they have made it
even harder for publishers
to actually start working
with subscriptions
and micro-payments
than it needed to be.
And here, many publishers in
Asia-Pacific, for example,
would say that
companies like WeChat--
the Tencent in China, their
social media platform, WeChat--
are ahead of where platform
companies are in the West.
And actually, that platform
companies in the West
could learn a lot from
e-commerce and social media
in China.
ERICA ANDERSON: Well, good.
We're taking notes.
Thank you.
I think that one thing
I want to mention--
and we'll go to
this question-- is
that from my perspective
on the News Lab,
and working with industry
partners and journalists
around the world,
one of the trends
that I'm seeing that I
think is really important
is utilizing and seeking more
information algorithmically
from journalists and
developers inside newsrooms
about the quality
of their content.
So a good example is--
or defining their content so
that we can more strategically
visualize it to consumers who--
there's a media literacy gap.
Is this an op-ed?
Is this analysis?
Is it reporting?
So we've launched a local
news tag, the fact check tag.
And you know, that's all
schema, open web markup.
And so I mention it.
It's technical.
It's in the weeds.
But I mention it because there's
this theme happening where
the platforms are trying to get
more information to showcase
the quality of the content
and to distinguish it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I thought the point about
the echo chamber and filters
was interesting, about
how people are actually
seeing content that they're
not normally exposed to.
I was wondering, when you're
doing your research, how
you account for
how people report
on what they behave versus
how they actually behave?
Because I know a
lot of the time,
people will say that
they read certain things
but in actuality, they won't.
So is there any kind
of research techniques
that you use to account
for that dichotomy?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Thanks.
I think you're spot-on.
I mean, that's a key challenge
in doing any kind of research
in this, in particular.
For this particular
research, we rely on recall.
So we have one set of questions
that are about asking people
to name sources of
news they've used
in the last week, where they're
prompted with a list of brands.
So that's where we know the
number of sources they've used.
And then a separate
set of questions
that are around the
ways in which people
say they come across news.
So for this particular analysis
of incidental exposure,
the figures both for
those who use social media
and those who don't are equally
susceptible to that problem
of recall-based
use, if you will.
So it shouldn't
disproportionately
affect either one of them.
The problem is real in the
sense most people don't recall
everything they've done
and don't report everything
they've done accurately either.
So there is a real problem
of recall versus behavior.
But in this particular
case, it should influence
both sides of that equation.
Now, a follow-up
piece of research
we did that was based on
actual behavioral data rather
than self-reported
data is the deep dive
I mentioned around attribution.
In that case, we passively
tracked a panel of--
I believe we had about 6,000
working with our partner
company, YouGov, in the UK,
about 6,000 people in the UK
for a month.
In that case, we
had behavioral data.
We knew what they had accessed.
And we could count up the
number of different sites
they had accessed.
We haven't released the full
breakdown of that analysis yet,
but I will foreshadow
now and say
that the general
thrust of that analysis
is the same, is that
social media use
and search again is consistently
and significantly associated
with more diverse views than
not using those ways of access.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about
any behavioral differences
you may have seen between the
people who actively seek news
out and those who
more come across it
on social media or elsewhere.
And then, if there
are differences,
is there a way to get that
second group of people
more engaged?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: I'm really
glad you asked that question.
I think that's, in many ways--
from my point of view, that's
probably the part of the public
that we should all think
the most about in the sense
that, frankly, the news and
information needs of people
like me are well-tended to.
There have never been a more
privileged and spoiled group
of media consumers
in human history
than people like me today.
I'll be fine.
But there is a question
of a much larger part
of the public who don't feel
motivated enough to seek out
journalism as we know it
today but may come across it
incidentally while doing
other things on social media.
We are trying to drill
more deeply into this
because we are very
interested in that question.
We think it's very important.
And we are particularly
concerned about this issue
that Erica also brought up of
news avoidance-- people who
say that they actively avoid
the news, asking them why
and thinking about the ways
in which they navigate news.
And I have to say that
the findings around that
are, I think, quite
sobering, both for journalism
and for the wider
public, and have
much less to do with technology
than one might imagine.
Fundamentally, a combination--
our qualitative research
in the UK would suggest a very
low opinion of journalism.
Seeing it as sensationalist,
crime-oriented, terrorist,
alarmist, or superficial
celebrity gossip material,
which I personally don't
think is a fair judgment
of journalism in its totality.
But I don't blame people
for holding that view.
I can find many examples
that would confirm
that view of journalism.
So a sense of it as both
irrelevant and depressing,
which is not something that
spurs much consumption,
combined with, I think,
a much deeper sense
of disempowerment and
alienation from public affairs.
A sense that since
people like me--
interviewees would say to us--
can't do anything about
all these terrible things
we are told about in the
news everyday, why should we
pay attention?
How does that make
my life better?
How does it make
my children's life
better that I know that all
sorts of terrible things
are going on that I could
do nothing to change?
So I think there are real
issues that journalism
need to confront there.
And if journalism
does that, I guess
I am optimistic that the
affordances of search
and social--
and increasingly,
messaging and the like--
will actually help
people who are not
that motivated to engage
with more of that content.
But the content has to be there.
And it can't only be
the kind of journalism
that presupposes that people
are like me, that they follow
with the obsession of
like a soap opera fanatic
and that I know all the
characters, and the drama,
and what was on yesterday,
and that I can tell
the difference between
what Trump said this day
and what Jeff Sessions
said the other day
and what John McCain
said the day before,
and what this, that,
and the other said.
If that's always the
premise, then you're
always only going
to be able to engage
with the already engaged.
And I think that is a real issue
now that we have to understand,
that publishers
have to understand
for the future of journalism
as a profession and the future
of their business, but
one I think researchers
can help to understand, too.
And hopefully,
platform companies
can help us begin to address
those issues to ensure
that the whole public is
informed and not only,
again, those who
are already engaged.
ERICA ANDERSON: Thank you.
Let's take one more question.
You want to ask a question?
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So first of all,
thank you for coming.
My question kind of relates to
the proliferation of fake news.
And I guess I'm wondering,
in terms of like search
engines and social media, are
news sites, like infowars.com,
[INAUDIBLE] news, sites
that are known to publish
just inaccurate information,
do you feel or do you know
if they've gotten, I guess like,
a jump on known trusted brands,
like The Washington
Post, Guardian, BBC,
in terms of investing
in things like SEO,
or partnerships with
social media platforms,
and different things like that?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Thanks.
What a fantastic round
of questions, by the way.
I think there are
initiatives underway now.
And Erica rightly
highlighted some of the ones
that Google are involved in.
But there are a couple
of different initiatives
also by other players, like
First Draft Coalition working
with tech companies
as well as publishers
to try to identify signals that
could be machine [INAUDIBLE]
to address some of these issues
around what kind of information
surfaces.
I think that's incredibly
important in part
because I think the real head
start that some sites have
who are not always equally
committed to the idea
of journalists being sort
of find truth and report it
or fact-based discourse is
more that you can express
your opinions about public
affairs a hell of a lot faster
than you can report on
what actually happened.
And as long as search
and social privileges
speed over almost
any other signal,
then there will inevitably be at
least a period of time in which
those who are brazen enough
to simply say what they think
has happened around
some public event
and promote it aggressively,
using SEO and SMO, and so
on and so forth, but just
saying what they think happened,
that will have at least
a window where they
dominate public discussion.
I think the broader issue
is that in terms of--
there's much that could be done.
And I'm glad to hear that
much of it is underway
and that people like yourself
with a journalistic background
are involved in this in
addition to technologists,
who need to be part of
solving this problem.
I think the next
complication, I suppose,
is that there are things
that are demonstrably false
and that are published either
with the intent of profiting
from it or with the
intent of influencing
political processes, whether
it's state-backed propaganda
or people who are
very ideologically
committed to a certain
view of the world
and do it as sort of
activists, if you will.
But I think there is a
much broader set of issues
that are more about
partisanship, if you will,
than they're about
being fake or false.
And that, I think, will be a
hard engineering challenge,
if you will.
I live in the UK.
The Guardian is a clearly
opinionated news organization.
The Mail Online is a clearly
opinionated news organizations.
They may publish things
that some people find
infuriating that
will be selective,
that will be partisan, that will
interpret things and perhaps
even sort of push an argument
to its outer boundaries,
if you will.
But they won't be fake.
And it will be very hard to
think of a technical solution
to adjudicating
that information,
or whether we even should want
a technical solution to that.
I personally believe that
we want a robust exchange
of views in public.
What we don't want is to reward
malicious misinformation, which
I think we have seen some
of in some countries.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERICA ANDERSON: Thank you.
Well, we're at the end.
I want to just ask you, since
we have you here, last question.
Next year, looking a year ahead.
If you could look into
your crystal ball,
what do you think
the headline will be?
What are you anticipating
might change?
I mean, is there anything
you're thinking about right now?
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: I mean,
I think the issue of trust
is one we really want
to try to bottom out.
And we'll do more
research in that area.
And I have taken some
suggestions today
from conversations here
and from conversations
with other publishers where we
are trying to understand better
the flow of information in
these more private environments,
like messaging apps, and really
trying to better track that.
But of course, we are
vulnerable to the issues
like the ones that were raised
by an earlier question--
that at the end of the
day, our ability to map
this stuff relies on
people actually telling us
what they're doing.
So we have some
ideas for next year.
And we will sort of try to
pursue them at our modest best.
And we also hope
for more suggestions
from people like yourself
as well as publishers
and academics and
researchers elsewhere
who, like us, are trying to
understand what the hell is
going on with news
and information
in this brave new world.
ERICA ANDERSON: Good.
Well, thank you so
much for coming.
RASMUS KLEIS NIELSEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]